what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like Marvel Studios has a
lot of plans up their sleeves as far as
what is going to happen in Phase 5 phase
six and phase seven there are a lot of
new reports out there today including
when to expect some specific Marvel
trailers which of course we'll talk
about in this video but perhaps the
biggest rumor right now is that Marvel
Studios is considering making Avengers
Secret Wars into two films and no I am
not talking about the Kang Dynasty being
part 1 and then Avengers Secret Wars
band part two I'm talking about having
the King Dynasty and then Secret Wars
part 1 and Secret Wars part 2. now
remember originally when Marvel revealed
Avengers Infinity War it was supposed to
be at first part 1 and then part two but
then they went on to name Avengers 4 AKA
Avengers Infinity War part 2 Avengers
end game even though they told us it was
an Avengers end game and then it was so
we could be getting an another movie a
part two of Secret Wars which I think
might actually be a good idea and I'll
explain why in this video but I'm
curious right away to hear what you
think would you like a part 1 and a part
two or would you simply just like the
King Dynasty and just one movie for
Avengers Secret Wars let us know right
now in the comments now there is good
and bad to this I think mostly good but
of course everybody can complain about
something if you have two movies this
leaves more room for error there's more
room for scenes that just might not be
that good now the hype for Avengers
Infinity war and Avengers end game was
insane these were some of the biggest
movie events of all time and I'm hoping
that it's going to be the same for the
King Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars
especially if we have a part 1 and part
two however if we do a part one and part
2 for Secret Wars that's really a three
movie event the Kang Dynasty and the two
secret Wars films they'll all be
connected and it will kind of seem like
a three part of it which can be a little
bit too much for people however I do
think that this actually is going to be
a good thing and the reason is because
we actually have a few projects in
between the King Dynasty and Avengers
Secret Wars now let's face it we pretty
much know that at the end of the Kang
Dynasty The Avengers aren't going to win
it's very much going to be like Thanos
winning at the end of Avengers Infinity
War actually based off of what we know
this is going to happen and the Avengers
are then going to have to seek the help
from other Heroes and other universes to
help save not only their universe but
the entire Multiverse and that's why we
get secret Wars after that and there's a
lot that can go into this if you caught
my video yesterday you probably know
that the Council of Kings is most likely
going to be coming to the MCU so it's
more than likely that we're going to
have to deal with not just one king but
multiple Kings in secret Wars but this
actually ties into why I think a
two-part movie would be better because
we could fit more in without it feeling
very cramped this also allows more room
and more time for Marvel Studios to
include the X-Men right now we know that
Kevin feige is taking his time with the
X-Men Fantastic Four are going to be
coming in phase six of course that is
confirmed but the X-Men have nothing
confirmed yet yes there have been teases
of them in the MCU so far like with Miss
Marvel and Namor but as far as an actual
X-Men team with the members that we know
and love like Professor Xavier Wolverine
Cyclops storm the more traditional X-Men
as far as we're concerned that's not
really going to happen until phase seven
however having a secret Wars part 1 and
part 2 could change that now I'm
assuming that part 1 and part 2 would be
decently spaced maybe a year apart and
that would be another downfall we would
have to wait a year or so until we get
the final conclusion of the Multiverse
Saga so this would essentially push back
the Multiverse Saga a year except it's
not really pushing it back it's just
extending it and during that year
extension they can add to the story and
add more Heroes we know Kevin feige is
taking his time with the X-Men because
he wants them to be fantastic of course
Kevin feige is an an eye in the
Fantastic Four for a very long time they
are his pride and joy so he has been
preparing for the Fantastic Four for a
very long time so his plans for them are
most likely all in order however the
X-Men are completely different and it's
not just a team of four there are so
many X-Men characters but having the
secret Wars allows him to include some
new characters in the MCU sooner rather
than later not having to wait till phase
seven so that is a pretty big positive
of having a secret Wars part 1 and a
part two and I'm always for having more
Marvel even if we have to wait another
year to get a final conclusion I'm okay
cause I'm here for the ride this could
also give it the potential to be the
biggest movie of all time if done
correctly the Multiverse has to be
explained in a way that is easy for the
general public to understand the people
who aren't on YouTube every day like us
if they do that secret Wars part 1 or
just Secret Wars in general if they
don't do two parts could be literally
insane for people but let's say they do
a part one and a part 2 and Secret Wars
part 1 is just phenomenal and then you
tease even more to come in the next film
even more different characters like the
X-Men say we have Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine in part one and then we tease
another Wolverine saying the post-credit
coming in part two that would just blow
everybody's minds and would definitely
get everybody super excited and ready to
go into the next movie part two or two
variants of Ryan Reynolds talking to
each other hashing it out bickering and
bantering back and forth with each other
in their super sarcastic way this would
freak everybody out and people would
just be so gung-ho about it and that's
an advantage that you could get with
having a part one and a part two plus
remember Avengers Infinity War didn't
have everybody together in one big scene
the entire movie in fact most of
infinity War they were broken off into
their groups then an end game after the
portal scene they all came together for
that final scene 45 minutes of
Awesomeness well imagine if we got more
than 45 minutes of everybody coming
together from different Multiverse
because I'm assuming that we are going
to show separate universes fighting on
their own so different Avengers teams
different Fantastic Fours but then we're
also going to see them come together as
well having a part one in part two gives
us more time to do this properly and not
feel rushed kind of like in Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness we thought
we were going to explore many different
universes but they kind of really didn't
it was done super briefly and we really
only explored two kind of three
different universes well this makes it
to where it doesn't have to be rushed
like that overall I think having a part
1 and part two would be a great idea
because it would give us more time and
Marvel Studios could do more and
introduce new characters without it
being super overwhelming but again like
I said let me know your thoughts about
this down below in the comments now we
do have some trailers coming up
including what is said to be the first
trailer for the Marvels where hopefully
we're going to start to see how Kamala
Khan's Bengal is connected to Captain
Marvel and how that's connected to King
and of course also the 10 rings as well
in the post-credits scene for shangchi
and the legend of the ten Rings Captain
Marvel got a distress signal and had to
go I'm curious to see what this was
about and maybe we'll get a little tease
of what it was about in the first teaser
trailer now this should be coming during
the Super Bowl we talked about this
before but now some more reports and
some insiders are stating that they've
heard that this is indeed true and of
course alongside of that since these
movies are coming before we're supposed
to get a special look at Ant-Man and the
wasp quantumania and then a new trailer
for Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 so
Marvel Studios seems to have some pretty
big plans for the Super Bowl plus not to
mention we could be getting some teasers
for Loki season 2 and secret Invasion as
well but well you know this is kind of
one of those perks of Disney owning a
lot Marvel Studios gets the time slots
that they need during the Super Bowl to
show basically whatever they want and
I'm here for it because I always love
more Marvel content so let me know how
excited you all are in the comments down
below and of course let us know what you
think about this idea for a part one and
a part two of Secret Wars be sure to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest MCU
news and what's happening of course you
can follow us on Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf